well we can get more now on those
bruising results for the conservatives
last night labor reclaimed wakefield in
west yorkshire with its new mp saying
that the party is rebuilding the red
wall simon lightwood was elected with a
majority of just under five thousand
well i'm joined now this morning by mary
cray the former mp for wakefield mary
craig good morning to you a red brick
back in the war absolutely and um
as the red wall starts to crumble for
the tories i think um that many more
will follow in that direction it's very
clear that the public has fallen out of
love with boris johnson and with
apocalyptic food prices with chaos at
airports and problems with supply lines
and scrapping of the hs2 leg to leads
that all the rhetoric they were promised
about levelling up and the northern
powerhouse has been forgotten and the
tory party now looks like a project to
keep one man in power
yeah so you what you're hearing is that
the the complaints of people who lent
their votes essentially to
the tory party is that this is all about
the man in charge absolutely and um they
want to know what's happened they sought
they voted to get brexit done and what
they're seeing is that it never seems to
be done and that the prime minister is
proposing to broke the oven red treaty
deal that he himself signed uh in order
to um appease some of the ultras in his
own party
um and they look at the cues on the m20
and the the price of petrol going up and
the price of food going up and they ask
uh you know britain isn't working for me
and i think people are tired i think
they're tired with politics as a chaotic
farce they're tired of sitting in the
dark they're tired of skipping meals and
they're tired of having to work for
their own poverty and i think starman
now has a big opportunity uh to get a
fair hearing from some of those voters
that we lost back in 2019.
yeah i mean we talk a lot about the red
wall don't we um
you'd think
that it shouldn't be that difficult for
the labour party to get it back given
the history
of labor
up there in in wakefield um but the
tories lost far more votes than labour
gained so
labor's going to have to do better
aren't they if they're going to start
rebuilding a solid foundation back again
in that war um simon's majority is is
bigger than any of my majorities post
2005
and don't forget there was a bus strike
in wakefield and an independent
candidate who took votes
whose power base really is in one of
wakefield labour's safest areas so i
would say it's a thumping win
i think it bodes well for any future
by-elections it certainly bodes well for
the general election and i think now
labour's path and labor's narrative
needs to be um building they finally
have a chance to be heard after such a
difficult time um you know ridding the
labour party of its uh toxic legacy of
jeremy corbyn um supporting what the
government was doing uh through covid
and uh now the war in ukraine so there's
it's been a very crowded couple of years
for kirsten's voice to be heard but i'm
confident that now it will be
is he the man though to win a general
election a recent poll by yougov had 51
percent of adults saying he is doing
badly as labour leader and 19 tellingly
don't know
well i think i think the 19 there people
haven't had a chance to to get to know
him to hear what he has to say
um but this is only the second time in a
quarter of a century that labour has
taken a seat back off the conservatives
and i think what that shows is that
certainly on the doorstep in wakefield
people were asking me what's labour's
defense policy so that the corbyn legacy
lingers on but people are now interested
in what what labour has to say
okay and in terms of labor strategy um
you can sort of see the potency of
tactical voting uh what what lessons for
for how you strategize going forward
i i think the labour party is a national
party it will be fielding candidates in
every seat of the next general election
um but i think we're seeing perhaps a
return to the tactical voting that we
saw back in 1997 where people are so um
repelled by the incumbents that they
decide that they are going to vote for
the candidate best placed to um oust the
incumbent conservative and i think we'll
see a lot more of that going forward but
the liberal liberal democrats never
polled particularly well in wakefield uh
anyway and this is around average for
for what we would see in in normal times
all right mary craig good to talk to you
thanks for your time this morning